President Biden is praising a
controversial prisoner swamp in
Venezuela over the weekend after months
of negotiations seven Americans were
exchanged for two convicted drug
smugglers who have ties to Venezuela's
ruler Nancy Cordis is at the White House
was more on that story Nancy good
morning to you so what do we know about
this deal Gail this was an exchange
plain and simple something the U.S
wanted for something Venezuela's
dictator wanted and what the U.S wanted
was to free seven Americans including
five houston-based Citgo oil Executives
who have been detained since 2017 on
what the U.S describes as bogus
corruption charges Venezuela agreed to
the release in exchange for these two
brothers who were jailed for years in
the U.S for drug smuggling these are not
just any brothers they are the nephews
of the wife of Venezuelan president
Nicholas Maduro CBS has learned that the
swap took place in the Caribbean nation
of Saint Vincent and the Grenadines
President Biden said this is part of his
quote administer registration's
unflinching commitment to keep Faith
with Americans held hostage and
wrongfully detained around the world but
some politicians argue this strategy
puts a price tag on Americans Florida
Senator Marco Rubio one of the senior
members of the Foreign Relations
Committee argued yesterday quote now
others know I can take Americans as a
bargaining chip U.S officials say these
are painful and difficult decisions they
say there are still about 60 Americans
who they consider to be wrongfully
detained around the world including U.S
basketball star Brittany Greiner in
Russia Nate
Nancy thank you